[Applause]
well again the resolution reads Focus
protection as set forth in the Great
Barrington declaration should be the
general principle of Public Health
Management of Highly infectious
respiratory virus pandemics uh welcome
not just to you in the audience but to
the scores of people who are watching
this right now on live streaming they
too can vote yes no or undecided on the
resolution and we hope you do we hope
everybody votes and I also want to again
invite you uh to the second mission of
the cell Forum not just to have debates
of interest to the larger Community to
Libertarians in particular but also to
have a party to have a place where
people can meet and discuss the debate
or discuss whatever else is on their
mind so if you bought a ticket to our
reception afterwards most of you
probably know the location shouldn't
follow me follow Nick follow some of us
just two blocks Uptown where uh the uh
the party is being catered by my
beautiful wife asako at our address at
55 great Jones Street right so uh
without any further delay uh we bring
you the main event of the evening
arguing for the affirmative Jade
bharacharya Jay please come to the stage
all right arguing for the negative Stan
Vermin Stan please come to the stage
okay uh Jay about Sharia you'll be
watching the time you uh you probably
want to take the podium okay probably
take the pudding for your talk and you
have 20 minutes to defend the resolution
take it away Jay
oh perfect fantastic thanks
thank you thank you for uh for uh
inviting me Gene and thank you Stan for
agreeing to debate uh we are in an era
where uh when we want to debate about
covet policy we have people like the NIH
director Francis Collins calling for
devastating takedowns of the opposition
and in that era it's really truly an
honor to have someone like Sten to to
talk civilly about these issues of
utmost importance because this is not
going to be the last pandemic that we
face and uh the it's a very real
possibility that the lockdown Focus
policy that we used a deviation from the
norm for how we've dealt with
respiratory virus pandemics in the past
will now become the new norm and that so
that throughout the rest of our lives
whenever there's a pandemic the threat
of of what happened the last three years
happening again and again and again will
repeat itself
so uh the the affirmative position talks
about the Great Barrington declaration
so let me just if those of you in the
room probably know what it is but let me
just tell you what what uh what is I'm
one of the primary co-authors along with
Martin kuldorf of Harvard and Sinatra
Gupta of Oxford University
um it's it's based on two very simple
scientific facts
first in the context of covid there's a
very steep age gradient in the the risk
profile of severe disease on infection
with covet eighty percent of the deaths
something on that order is is uh have
occurred in people over the age of 65.
and so an age as a the primary risk
factor that most easily identifiable
risk factor for covert there are other
risk factors diabetes obesity but they
are not nearly as steep as age in as far
as the risk of dying from infection
that's fact one
Fact Two
the uh the lockdowns themselves have
been incredibly damaging damaging to
everybody I'll talk through some of the
the harms but I could spend my entire 20
minutes and knock anywhere near close to
cataloging them because they transform
the lives of nearly every single human
being and for poor people around the
world they've been particularly
devastating for young people for
children they've been devastating
um so if you put these two facts
together covet is is a severe disease
for older people
for younger people much less so
for uh the lockdowns are incredibly
damaging the lockdowns then impose an
undue burden on the Young on on people
who are lower risk
and therefore the first plank of the
Great Britain declaration is to lift the
lockdowns and never impose them again
the second Plank and probably the you
know equally important is focus
protection of the vulnerable and the
older populations I'll talk a little bit
about how we propose to do that during
the pandemic um and uh ideas for how to
do that in the next respiratory viral
pandemic
um because this principle is is
generalizable right those those two
planks those two ideas are very are
actually
although we don't know what the next
respiratory viral pandemic will look
like we don't know yet what the risk
factors are
we can use them to try to identify the
risk factors
um but what's the alternative what's the
alternative well we just lived through
one we lived through this lockdown
focused strategy for managing the
respiratory viral pandemic
um it falls on me to Define what a
lockdown is a lot of times I come in and
say a lot of people ask me what what it
is
um the the the the idea of a lockdown I
in my view is any policy
designed to prevent people from
breathing in the vicinity of one another
or touching one another
any policy designed to prevent people
breathing on one another or touching one
another
um so this includes for instance the
mass quarantine of large numbers of
healthy people shelter and place orders
business closures
church and and mosque and and synagogue
closures it's
closures of schools all of that count is
locked down obviously but it also
includes strategies like in the UK
employing propaganda techniques
explicitly by the government to to
spew fear in the population in the U.S
uh strong recommendations to social
distance to stay away from other people
to treat everybody else as a Biohazard
right that is of that in that in my view
is a lockdown
um and the tools to enforce it include
both propaganda tools and as well wide
scale censoring smearing and demeaning
of people who oppose it including people
with with with credentials just to speak
up
um so that's one alternative what we
just experienced
to focus protection the other
alternative is to let the virus rip to
essentially do nothing let older
populations die uh and and and hope that
hope the disease just goes away
um while that sounds inhumane it is
inhumane in some very poor parts of the
world
the capacity to do anything else is
really not not in place in the attempt
to do lockdown has done incredible harm
so those are the two Alternatives that
we that we're talking about and I think
both Sten and I can agree that let it
rip is not the right alternative that if
it's possible uh to do something to
protect vulnerable people we must do
that so it's an ethical must
uh so so with that in mind the two
alternatives are focused protection and
and lockdown
failure or Focus protect of lockdown
focused coveted response is all around
us
and it's really important to understand
why the lockdowns failed and I can just
tell you this with with a couple of
simple data points
in the early days when the lockdowns
were imposed in Toronto Canada
if you look at the graph of where the
case is spread and they spread despite
the lockdowns there in the 30 poorest
neighborhoods there was an enormous
spread of cases
in the 30 rich neighborhoods almost none
the same thing happened in Los Angeles
all through 2020 if you look at the
age-adjusted mortality and age-adjusted
case rates from covid in Los Angeles
it's the poorest neighborhoods where the
disease spread and the richest
neighborhoods much less so it's the
communities where ethnic minorities live
where the disease spread
it's the communities where white
populations live where it didn't in Los
Angeles
the lockdowns are not are people are not
uniformly capable of coping with
lockdowns they are a luxury of the rich
the lockdowns are a luxury of the Rich
and a specific kind of Rich the luxury
of the laptop class the in the United
States something like 20 percent of the
population
could afford to do a lockdown without
losing their jobs without fearing a loss
of livelihood
that's not true for most of the
population in fact
um the and there there just isn't it's
not humanely possible to do something
like what China is attempting over an
extended period of time without
civil rights violations on a wide scale
that harm the poorest the most
vulnerable the working class populations
the most
and eventually and pretty soon most of
the population except for the laptop
class will not be able to comply with
the lockdowns we need to be in community
with one another we're built for that
kind of community and asking people for
an extended period of time to stay out
of that Community is inhumane and is
bound to fail and cause great damage in
the meantime
um the the lockdowns uh the harms of the
lockdowns were tremendous
the closed schools were seeing deep
learning loss especially in the
communities that locked down the highest
um the the uh it's it's poor families
that were unable to to replace the
education the actually lack of Education
the zoom School represented
that have faced the worst of the
learning losses
we have created a generational
inequality that will take tremendous
effort to address if it's at all
possible to do so and it's not just that
there's learning loss the evidence from
before the pandemic on the importance of
school suggests that these have these
learning losses have long consequences
in the lives of our children one
estimate for early in the pandemic
suggested the spring closures alone cost
our children five and a half million
life years
why because when children don't go to
school for it turns out for even short
periods of time they lead poorer shorter
less healthy lives which is what we
decided when we decided to close the
schools
harm to poor countries or even more
tremendous
effect on the on the on the on poverty
so we we globalized the world over the
last last 40 40 years we we
systematically uh drop trade barriers
created these this global global system
and poor countries reorganize their
economies to fit in
when we locked down when we broke Supply
chains the pointy end of that were poor
people in informal sectors in poor
countries 100 million extra people
thrown into poverty as a consequence of
the lockdown tens of millions of people
on the brink of starvation in March of
2021 the U.N issued a report suggesting
that 230 000 children had died from
starvation caused by the economic
dislocation of the lockdowns and it's
not just the lockdowns imposed in the in
the poor countries it's the it's the
Western lockdowns which had Ripple
effects on the economies of the poor
countries
um uh the the lockdowns were bound to
fail because the the Z's spread even
before we knew it in the early days of
the pandemic I did a study of the
prevalence of the disease in Santa Clara
County and also in Los Angeles County it
was roughly three or four percent was
the prevalence we found I mean that's a
that's a big number actually uh three or
four percent it was much higher than the
number of people that had been
identified as cases the disease had
arrived and spread in the United States
long before we knew it there are
antibody studies from blood banks in
stored blood from Angola from Italy from
October of 2019 suggesting that perhaps
the disease was already seeded then
it was by the time the lockdowns arrived
it was too late and that will be true in
the next pandemic as well we do not have
surveillance systems that allow us to
guarantee picking up the the a highly
infectious respiratory virus pandemic
before before it starts
um the focus protection as a general
pandemic plan is actually not even a
novel idea right we use this standard
pandemic plant in a century respiratory
virus pandemics 1957 1968 1976 something
like Focus even 2009 we did not lock
down despite widespread uh
deadly respiratory virus pandemics
Woodstock happened during a pandemic
the identification of risk factors
regarding who's at highest risk and poor
in in our in the case of covet is age it
may be something else in the next
pandemic so it's hard to say let's
follow exactly these policies but the
principle of focus protection
identifying whose highest risk moving
Heaven and Earth protect them while not
disrupting the rest of society is a
principle that we can apply very
generally
um focus protection is necessarily a
local task it requires creativity at the
local level during this pandemic what it
required was that people
uh local public health officials who
know how older people live in their
communities
engage creatively think of ideas to
protect the community members as they
live there the policies followed in
Billings Montana are certain to be very
different than the the right policies to
follow in Los Angeles or in Stockholm
um the uh the the uh just just to give
an example of this of things that we
could have done but didn't in Los
Angeles
hotels where hotel rooms during the
pandemic were provided to to homeless
populations which is fine but they
weren't provided to elderly people
living in multi-generational homes often
poor Hispanic populations when someone
you know Johnny comes home or calls
grandma says Grandma I think I've been
exposed to covet grandma could have
called local public health and a hotel
room provided until Johnny was cleared
right those kinds of ideas could have
been used at scale for the trillions of
dollars we spent but there weren't
because we didn't creatively decide to
protect vulnerable older people instead
relying on lockdowns to control
Community spread instead
which obviously failed uh the protection
of Hospital Systems
um it was was a main argument for
lockdowns
um the problem is that
you actually don't need to lock down to
protect Hospital Systems Focus
protection does the job who's at highest
risk for hospitalization
well it's it's older people if you
protect older people while you reduce
the burden on Hospital Systems Hospital
systems and there's not just demand side
policies also supply side policies we
rapidly built facilities to manage
patients for overflow in in New York in
Los Angeles and Santa Clara in in San
Francisco and actually all of those
facilities went unused
you know the Javits Center the mercy
ship and so on
um the the what's the what's the upshot
of this
the upshot is that if you do a policy of
of lockdown of trying to to suppress the
spread of the disease or to to protect
Hospital Systems you essentially split
goals and this is a world filled with
trade-offs
um why did Andrew Cuomo send covet
infected patients back to nursing homes
why did that happen in Stockholm why did
that happen in Montreal why did that
happen in Pennsylvania it happened
because instead of focused protection of
vulnerable people being the goal we
instead decided the protection of
Hospital Systems was the goal
If instead we decided that Focus
protection of older people who at
highest risk for the goal we could have
done what happened for instance in
Florida quarantine hospitals quarantines
centers intermediate between nursing
homes and hospitals where coveted
infected patients were sent to
convalesce before they were sent back to
hospitals not before the set of nursing
homes
um what's the end point of all this the
the end point is immunity
this is something that early in the
pandemic it was as it was taboo to say
if you get coveted and recover you do
get an immunity now this is a
coronavirus the kind of herd immunity
that you get is very different than the
kind of herd immunity that you would get
from measles measles you get measles and
you recover and you are you're going to
have immunity forever against getting
measles again
with this
virus what happens is you get covid you
recover and you can get covet again
especially if there's new variants but
what seems likely and it's just like
it's true with the other coronaviruses
the second time you get it it's going to
be less severe than the first time
that's not a guaranteed Ironclad rule
but it's likely and that that plays out
in epidemiological data all over the
place
um so the end point is herd immunity
that has always been the end point we
have no technology to protect any
population forever from a highly
infectious respiratory virus we have no
technology to protect any population
forever except maybe someone like Howard
Hughes you know stick up in in his uh in
his in his mansion
um okay so uh the end point then is
immunity even focused protection can't
be permanent the idea is to protect
older people until you develop better
ways to treat the disease better ways to
to vaccinate better ways to manage the
disease very quickly in the pandemic for
instance we learned that that steroids
were a very effective way to manage
patients in the hospital we didn't know
that at the beginning a focus protection
strategy until we started to learn about
the disease is is a way to reduce the
net harmful disease because then the
most vulnerable people get the disease
last
um okay I want to finish with some
ethical principles of Public Health that
I think were violated during the
pandemic that are consistent with
focused protection but not consistent
with lockdown and I'll just reach on
that this is something that I wrote with
uh with some some of my colleagues
um so one all public health advice
should consider the impact on overall
health rather than solely be concerned
with a single disease it should always
consider the benefits and harms on
public health measures and weigh the
short term versus the long term
this is exactly what Focus protection
does it considers the whole person
rather than and doesn't just say that
the only harm to our health is is covet
in fact there are many many threats to
our health of the population people who
are not vulnerable to covet are
vulnerable to many other things
two public health is about everyone any
public health policy must first and
foremost protect society's most
vulnerable
including children low-income families
persons with disability and the elderly
should never shift the burden of disease
from the affluent to the less affluent
which is exactly what Focus protection
did a trickle-down epidemiology policy
where the theory look lockdowns or
trickled epidemiology policy where the
idea is that if we protect the super uh
the laptop class everyone else is
protected
three Public Health advice should be
adapted to the needs of each population
within cultural religious Geographic and
other contexts if you believe that
church is vital is essential if you
believe that synagogues are essential
that Moscow essential
than they are and public health needs to
acknowledge that four public health is
about comparative risk evaluations risk
reductions and reducing uncertainties
using the best available scientific
evidence since risk cannot usually be
entirely eliminated
that that idea that we have to live with
risk there is no perfect there's only
trade-offs is Central to Public Health
and and something that the public was
misled about during the pandemic five
Public Health requires public trust
Public Health recommendations should
present facts as the basis for guidance
and never employ fear or shame or sway
to manipulate the public and I should
say the public health should always
issue Noble lies Noble lies undermine
trust in public health
six medical interventions should not be
forced or coerced on a population but
rather should be voluntary and based on
informed consent Public Health officials
are advisors not rule Setters and
provide information and resources for
individuals to make informed decisions
7. Public Health authorities must be
honest and transparent both with what is
known and is what is not known advice
should be evidence-based and explained
by data authorities must acknowledge
errors and changes in evidence as soon
as they are made aware of them we should
not have people in charge Public Health
who believe that they are science itself
hey
three more guys Public Health scientists
and practitioners should avoid conflicts
of interest and any unavoidable
conflicts of interest must be clearly
stated that's that's been a problem
through the pandemic both pharmaceutical
companies and as well
Public Health officials who control
research budgets also being deeply
involved in public health policy setting
nine in public health open civilized
debate is profoundly important what
we're doing here is vital and it's
unacceptable for public health
professionals to censor silence or
intimidate members of the public or
other public health scientists or
practitioners which has happened during
the pandemic and last one I'll be all
done it's critical for public health
scientists and practitioners always to
listen to the public who are living with
the public health consequences of Public
Health decisions and to adapt
appropriately uh thank you very much
thank you
Stan German you get one extra minute for
your presentation good because Jay took
one extra minute
it's okay thank you Jay very articulate
very inspiring
but uh we're going to have a difference
of opinion this evening so
um Public Health
um is many things
and what we're talking about tonight is
a communicable disease control that is
one tiny sliver of Public Health but
there are others for example uh the
environment
toxic waste dumps and uh
the the world of Social and Behavioral
Science the social determinants of
disease
and we're all
um in it together
so the fundamental truth in public
health especially for communicable
diseases is that there is a social
compact as much as we would like to be
um
valuing individual liberty all the time
everywhere
if there is an active tuberculosis
patient
or individual on the subway and that
individual is coughing that individual
may very well infect people around him
or her
and every state in the Union has a law
that permits Public Health officials to
actually lock up such a person
because of the weight of burden on the
Public's health
we violate the individual liberty of
that individual to go free
we know that Typhoid Mary spent
substantial time in a local Island when
she refused to give up her her career as
a itinerant cook
because she was
infecting her patients at least
apocryphally she was
and we have many other examples of where
infectious agents that cannot be
controlled
are subject to things like isolation and
all the rest so let's turn back the
clock
to February 28th I think it was 2020.
where
um
a CDC official who's now the dean of the
jilling School of Public Health at UNC
uh Dr messenger
announced that we were in trouble she
was the head of respiratory diseases at
CDC at the time
and that we were going to have to
mobilize to control what seemed to be a
global pandemic because we had seen the
devastation in Wuhan China
the deaths in that City in December
January of that year
and we were seeing deaths now in Europe
Italy and elsewhere
and she predicted that this would come
to the U.S
she was promptly shut down by the White
House at that time and you barely heard
from her the rest of the pandemic it was
politicized that early
and the reality was she was absolutely
right
I had two friends die in early 2020 Dr
Gita ramji an immensely talented
reproductive health expert
world-renowned Dr James Hakeem World
expert in in HIV disease they both died
they were both in their early 60s
neither of them had any risk factors so
I was alarmed by the loss of friends of
mine and I was alarmed by the magnitude
of the pandemic
um yes we have pandemics quite routinely
1960s 1957 1968 even in the 20 21st
century we have had pandemic flu the
differential between an average flu
season and a pandemic flu season is
about ten thousand to fifty thousand
now we've had a million people die
of coronavirus in the span of about two
years
so the magnitude of what we were up
against in the early 2020 time period
was completely unlike anything that we'd
experienced for a century you have to go
back to
the so-called Spanish Flu of 1918 1919 a
bit of misnomer
Spain didn't have censorship of their of
their of their newspapers because they
were not combatants in World War one so
that was the only newspaper a pool in
Europe that actually reported uh
influenza the time because everybody
else suppressed it in any case that was
probably 40 percent worse than covid and
many times worse than any other pandemic
threat so it was a unique time in 2020
many of you lived through it here in New
York City I lived through it in
Connecticut we were hit hard very early
and we were filling up our our hospitals
with dead and dying patients
uh in Yale New Haven Hospital it's the
second second largest hospital in the
United States
uh with uh over 1500 beds we had 450
patients
um in our hospital at that in in April
of uh 2020
and we had 143 deaths that month
which was
astronomical
for a hospital of that sophistication to
have an unknown disease come into the
hospital we had to open up three new
floors
to accommodate the ICU beds many of our
doctors didn't go home for three four
five weeks at a time
because they were afraid of infecting
their families and they were needed in
the hospital
the the stress was absolutely
mind-boggling
now
this is with
a fairly aggressive lockdown policy
but my distinguished opponent would lead
you to believe that if we had done much
less
we would have been much better off
and I maintain that when we had a
pandemic
a raspberry virus of this magnitude
that we didn't know what we're up
against we hadn't seen this in 100 years
so we needed to deploy many different
layers of protection to see if we could
put a stop to it this included masking
this included physical distancing it it
included lockdowns it included hygiene
it included reform of of HVAC systems
and uh and and improving indoor air
quality pivoting to outdoor activities
and all the things you're very familiar
with
now when we think about
so-called protecting the vulnerable the
entire backbone of the
focused protection scheme
uh
we have no plan for such a thing we have
four percent of the population in the
United States that is immunosuppressed
and only about half those people know
that they're immunosuppressed
furthermore we have vast populations in
our nursing homes in the state of
Connecticut there are about 17 500
people in nursing homes
and in 2020 we had 3 500 of them die
that was a 20
mortality rate
and in reality we didn't have any
provision for focused protection there
was no uh pool of empty hotel rooms to
transfer the the nursing home patients
too there was no uh Workforce that we
could deploy so that uh so that people
working in nursing homes could not have
two jobs and could just be resting in
place in one nursing home we had no real
plan for such a respiratory disease of
that magnitude hence
the um
lockdowns
were essentially a desperation measure
essentially something that we did as the
rates were skyrocketing to try to reach
an asymptote and start dropping them
by
um May of 2020
in state of Connecticut we had a
reopened Connecticut task force report
describing how we could end the
lockdowns which we largely did in later
that year
we also were able to reopen our schools
there was only one major School District
in the state that did not reopen in the
Autumn so that Jay and I see eye to eye
on the merits of using
um
radical Public Health measures as
briefly as possible but Jay would have
done something that he has not defined
for us he talks about
Focus protection but we have heard
nothing about how he would identify the
immunosuppressed people and keep them
safe how he would segregate all of the
elderly people in the United States from
all the rest of us and let the virus
sweep through the rest of us we would
pay a price we would have a few children
die there have been 680 children who've
died of Cove in the United States the
last time I checked we would have young
people die like my friends who were in
their early 60s we would have people
even Younger die and we would sweep
through the population
tolerate those deaths and magically
segregate our elderly and our
immunosuppressed well we don't know how
to do that we have no plan to do that we
have no financing to do that and we
couldn't have done that so Focus
protection in my view is a pipe dream
it's a theoretical concept that sounds
appealing on a debate stage but the
reality of what we were up against in
public health
was a surging pandemic of an
unprecedented virus that we had not seen
it's like since the pandemic influenza
1918-1919 which was of somewhat
comparable level
everything that Jay has said about the
harms of lockdowns I understand I work
tirelessly to try to keep schools open
in the state of Connecticut I worked
even with Rhode Island with schools here
in New York City schools in California
and trying my best as a pediatrician and
infectious disease epidemiologists to
combine my skill set to try to keep
children in school so I I sympathize
completely with the harms that excessive
lockdowns or unreasonable policies
resulted on the other hand I absolutely
feel that focused protection is not a
defined concept
there is only one place that I'm aware
that they tried this at a national scale
and that's the country of Sweden
so in Sweden typically you think about
Sweden
my parents home country of Norway
Denmark Finland Iceland in the same
breath you think well
similar policies great deal of
coordination that usually is true
but in this case Sweden took a very
different position because of the point
of view of its head to epidemiologists
and they adopted a focused protection
scheme
so um
pregnant women had four times the
hospitalization rate for covid in Sweden
than any of the other Scandinavian
countries there were 14.3 excess deaths
per hundred thousand hundred thousand
population in Sweden in 2020 versus no
excess deaths in Denmark and Norway
there was a full capacity
Surge and crisis in Swedish hospitals by
December of 2020 there was no such
crisis in the rest of Scandinavia
um there was a
case rates 7.8 per thousand uh in Sweden
and between 1.4 and 2.4 per thousand in
Norway Denmark and Finland uh
um almost three and a half fold
excess test positivity rates in Sweden
were 9.7 percent they were between one
and two percent in Norway Denmark and
Finland and deaths in Sweden from covid
were 11 and a half times greater than in
Norway
5.1 times greater than in Denmark and
9.1 times greater than in Finland
um furthermore uh what the Finn what the
swedes are trying to do which is
preserve their economy didn't work
either and uh Irfan had all were
publishing just a few months ago in the
Journal of global health
saw that there was no trade-off between
the economy and Public Health in other
words the swedes suffered as much
economic loss as the Norwegians and
Danes did
because frankly it was a global
catastrophe no Global pandemic crisis so
the borders were being closed uh
something the Suites couldn't do
anything about
I could go on and on about Sweden but it
uh it was the swedes themselves that
recognized what a catastrophic approach
they had taken and uh in November of
2020 they established a distancing and
uh an isolation policy which started to
mimic what we had done much earlier in
the year
now I give this to you as a natural
experiment a natural experiment is where
you don't you don't randomize countries
and say well we'll randomize Sweden over
here and everybody else over there but
it just happened that they had a
different policy but the but the
cultures and the background populations
are so similar across these countries
that reasonable epidemiologists conclude
that it was the Swedish policy of
so-called Focus protection that did not
work and that ended up with um with this
kind of Crisis circumstance I'll um also
mention a few of the points that Jay
highlighted and we we call each other by
our first names because we know each
other having debated twice before
um
the issue of the age gradation of covid
is that five seconds or five minutes
minutes thank you so um
age gradation of covid
flu typically is worse in the very young
and the very old
so my age group as a pediatrician the
under twos
and the geriatricians age group
um the pandemic influenza of 1918 and
1919
actually disproportionately hit people
of middle age
and it was also influenza
now covid in the SARS example and in the
mirrors example both covid viruses of
quite devastating capacity that hit us
in
2003 2004 with SARS and then
um in in about 2009 to about 2017 MERS
the Middle East Respiratory those are
both serious coronaviruses that have
higher
infection fatality rates than than covet
does uh but they're not as infectious
and they they the Saras Afflicted 8 000
people as opposed to
tens of millions of people probably
hundreds hundreds of millions of people
around the world
so they're different circumstances but
the reason I mention it is all of them
have different age groups that are being
Afflicted so we didn't know
the degree to which
um we were we were we were dealing with
a virus that was sort of uh excessive in
the elderly nor if we had known because
we knew that sort of by summer but if we
had known that even earlier we probably
couldn't have done anything about it
because the
point that Jay made was there was no way
to extract the elderly from the
households there was no way to shut down
our nursing homes and magically disperse
them there was no way to identify the
immunosuppressed people who hadn't been
diagnosed yet so it was a collective
decision and a collective goal to try to
reduce Transmission in the general
population and thereby protect the most
vulnerable Among Us
I don't think that was unreasonable even
I think a Libertarian would not see that
as unreasonable as long as it's being
managed in an intelligent way which it
wasn't always managed intelligent way
I'll give you I'll give my distinguished
opponent at that point
now I would also like to make the issue
of the lockdowns being damaging in an
undue burden on the young
this I find to be
um
a paradoxical statement because we're
talking about the death of the elderly
the death of the humanist press we're
talking about very serious consequences
of a pandemic respiratory disease for
which we had no treatments for which we
had no vaccines and
um
that should have been our focus and was
our Focus
and that young people suffered is a a
very unfortunate side effect but the
best
circumstances were the ones in which
lockdowns were transient uh safe
reopening was made feasible a
remediation of
building air systems was made possible
separation was possible say separating
children three to six feet in schools
masking was was encouraged Etc and in
safe reopening we I think had the best
of both worlds we were able to protect
the vulnerable in a time of extreme
crisis
and as treatments as vaccines came on
board until that time we were able to
keep much of our population safe so I I
don't believe that undue burden on the
young is a good argument I also feel
that um
the harms of closures does not logically
lead to the focused protection strategy
I would ask in rebuttal if my
distinguished opponent would tell us
how he would propose to to disperse the
vulnerable elderly into safe isolated
zones because that's functionally what a
focus protection is alternatively one
could group them into camps and have all
the vulnerable people together which I
think is a public health professional I
think is a very bad idea one person
getting in you have a wildfire within
that environment so let's get specific
Jay tell us what Focus protection is
tell us how you would operationalize it
and since we were not in a position to
do that in March April May of 2020 why
what we did was so terrible thank you
foreign
thank you Stan so uh there's a few
points to send make I want to I wanted
to focus a little bit on um so first uh
Sten mentioned the harm from the
pandemic million people dead in the
United States uh with you know with
covid
um I agree the problem was that we did
not take the disease seriously enough
uh contrary to what Stan said we
actually knew from the earliest days of
the pandemic about the age gradient uh
there was that there was a ship the
Diamond Princess Cruise where almost
every single death was people older
people the data out of China told us
from the earliest days of the pandemic
there was older people that were highest
risk and we did not take that signal
strongly enough we didn't move Heaven
and Earth to protect the people that are
most vulnerable instead relying on
lockdown uh Sten mentioned the the
trauma of seeing patients die I I've
seen from my colleagues at Stanford the
same a lot of doctors were quite afraid
of treating coveted patients because it
was an unknown disease and the trauma
they described to me the trauma of
seeing patients die uh I I agree with
that the problem is that this trauma led
to bad policy in fact this this the dean
of Stanford medicine told me when I
asked him if we could have a debate like
this in 2020 uh in what he said that it
was too early to have a dispassionate
academic discussion about policy because
people were too too still too
traumatized from the from from the
experience in March the Panic that led
to the lockdown meant that the lockdowns
could not be transient the Panic fueled
more panic and into 2020 and 2021 we
adopted policies designed to treat each
other's biohazards
it's not possible to have a transient
lockdown without panicking the
population because we've learned through
this pandemic
um it also leads to the adoption of
non-evidence-based policies
right so uh why did Public Health tell
you that wearing cloth masks would
protect you when there was literally no
evidence that was true that very likely
led to Deaths because people who were
vulnerable Warcraft mask went out in
public when they uh they and they were
not protected from the disease even
though they thought they were
um so the idea that lockdown induced and
adopted in panic is the right approach I
just I don't I don't agree with Sten
asked for a plan for Focus protection
that's completely reasonable the plan I
call for and I mentioned during my talk
is for local public health to engage
creatively with the living circumstances
of the old I do not support segregating
people people on the camps if someone
when I'm 85 and my grandson or
granddaughter comes up to me and gives
me a hug even though there's a pandemic
on I'm going to hug them even if I'm at
high risk I want to preserve that
possibility but you can adopt policies
to not send coveted infected patients to
nursing homes
right because you're not protecting I
mean who are you protecting you're
trying to protect uh hospitals I guess
um you can you can adopt policies to
make resources available uh there were a
lot of hotel rooms available uh and we
spent six trillion dollars the what was
lacking was creative thinking about how
to apply Focus protection in local
communities
um so I I don't I think the uh the the
straw man argument of of camps for
grandmas is not focus protection that
treats Health as if only infectious
disease controls is is concerned as well
it's not finally Sweden
um the the uh the the thing that what's
what's the the statistics uh that that
you got from Stan on on Sweden actually
were 2020 statistics in 2020 Sweden
failed to protect older people in
Stockholm they sent covert infected
patients back to nursing homes causing a
tremendous death that was not focused
protection
what they got right was keeping schools
open
in fact through the pandemic uh the the
uh the the kids under 15 all went to
school in Sweden Norway which closed
schools for a short time actually
apologized to the population for having
done so because it was an enormous
mistake which I think Sten will agree
with
um and so I think um it's it's to to
characterize Swedish outcomes as that is
actually really really not right if you
look through the pandemic they have
lower all-cause excess deaths than
Finland roughly the same as Norway
roughly the same as Denmark and much
lower than the rest of Europe
in fact a Swedish experience turned out
to be quite good in November 2020 they
did adopt a slightly more harsh policy
in in that they recommended social
distancing when the disease was
spreading rapidly which is a completely
consistent with social with Focus
protection especially if you do that
make that recommendation to older people
and tell people who's really at highest
risk so I think practically Focus
protection can work it requires
creativity it requires deployment of
resources and requires not panicking on
the other hand lockdown we've seen it
fail it'll fail again it'll cause all
the harms that I've mentioned before
again and again until we decide as a
community as a nation as a world to
project it thank you
[Applause]
the Swedish experience was very good I
don't know many professionals who would
agree with that the statistics don't lie
and in 2020 the swedes were with
nine times the the death rates of
neighbors it was a grim circumstance
what they did was they changed their
policy
what they did was they instituted
precisely some of the separation and uh
and um and uh cautionary notes uh you
saw masks go on in Sweden in public
places you saw uh small groups being
banned they were not allowed to have
groups bigger than a certain amount all
the same things we did at Yale
University
and
um that is why circumstances improved in
Sweden not because
focused protection was working but it
was actually not working and they had to
back back away from that strategy
um Jay and I actually agree on the
issues of schools and I think I
mentioned in my comments that I spent a
good part of my 2020 2021 working with
schools to help keep them open safely I
did the same with Arts organizations so
like the sheen Center to try to help
them reopen Etc so I do agree with Jay
that
um
that
we could do much better
with a middle ground
not absolute lockdown all the time
months after month after month not
overreacting so in that sense as is
sometimes the case in debates one sees
common ground
but the lockdowns as far as I'm
concerned we really had no alternative
we had dying patients we didn't have
plans we
um were desperate to stem the
unremittingly Grim March of mortality
and incidents
filling our hospitals filling our icus
overwhelming our health system and if
there's one thing about a respiratory
disease that we know is that you can
reduce its its transmission if you keep
people apart
I am
um aware of the laptop uh argument white
collar workers had a much easier time
keeping their jobs and working from home
than blue collar workers did there's no
question that blue collar workers were
disadvantaged and were in a position
where uh they might put themselves In
Harm's Way
and uh and the social determinants of
disease predate uh the covet pandemic
and will be here after the coven
pandemic is less of a public health
emergency because the United States
spends a disproportionate amount of
money on its health system and not
enough on its social system so we have
no problem taking a homeless individual
into the in the hospital for diabetic
ketoacidosis or or or
asthma and uh and uh and sub-optimally
placing them in a community because the
hospital doesn't have
uh housing stock and at the end of the
day we we coordinate that extremely
poorly and uh and this is one of the
reasons we have the highest expenditures
for health of any uh High income country
in in the world uh with some of the
worst outcomes
because we've got distorted a view of
what we're going to spend money on we
won't house a homeless person but we
will spend whatever it takes to treat
them in a hospital it makes no sense
it's not what the Europeans do and I
think that that laptop story is not
unique to covet it's it's Universal in
all of our circumstances
I do think that that lockdowns in
informed constituencies were transient
they weren't as bad in the state of
Connecticut as uh Jay would have you
believe we did have a plan to reopen the
state uh in 2020 we did operational
operationalize that plan and I think we
mitigated some of the social harms uh
now cloth masks I I think we could talk
about all night because two ply cloth
masks did okay with uh the ancestral
strain didn't do as well with Delta
didn't do as well with with Omicron but
I think when there was a shortage of
surgical masks kn95 masks cloth cloth
masks were a clever idea that's what I
said in the article I wrote in March of
2020 thank you
foreign
thanks to you both we now go to the Q a
portion of the evening and it does
consist of questions from the audience I
can line up and ask questions it also
consists of you uh either side having
the option to ask the other a question
at any time exercising that option it
also includes moderators prerogative let
me start a little bit with moderate's
prerogative if you'll permit me a
question for Jay and for Stan to comment
uh uh Stan mentioned
immunosuppressed people you speak about
the age gradient but then you also
concede that there are other vulnerable
people is that the immunosuppressed
people difficult to recognize and how
would you deal with that with Focus
protection so it's the image suppression
is a complicated question so for
instance there's a study out of France
that suggests that immunosuppressed
children did no worse with covert than
non-union suppressed children I I don't
think that result holds for adults but
that's that's it's it the reaction to
covid whether you're high risk or not is
an empirical question and because your
immunosuppressed doesn't automatically
make you high risk it just it just
depends it's a hard question I mean like
that is I completely Grant you uh I
don't think the lockdowns did a very
good job protecting those populations
especially those who don't know they're
immunosuppressed I don't know I don't
know of any policy that would protect
them from that so I think it's it's a
difficult question and there's really
not a fantastic answer that I can give
you you have to work with the the data
you have age is a risk factor we knew
that early on diabetes is a risk factor
we knew that early on work with those
the things that you know and work really
hard to learn more so that the the the
degree of ignorance is less and really
there's no other alternative it's a
world unfortunately filled with
trade-offs immunosuppressed people know
that they're at risk even from other
infectious diseases not just covid so in
that sense they have a leg up the ones
who don't know it's really just a very
difficult challenge for everything
coming from you stand or you want to
know
there's a
yeah I think I think can you hear me
yeah I think there is a uh Jay is
absolutely right there's a substantial
diversity in uh the pool of the four
percent of us who are immunosuppressed
someone can be battling cancer
um and taking in Express drugs be
profoundly immunosuppressed be at very
high risk of what we sometimes call
opportunistic infections of which covet
could be won coronavirus could be one uh
and then there are people who are mildly
immunosuppressed so there is
heterogeneity in that pool but I think
it's well understood that uh folks who
are elderly folks who are
immunosuppressed folks with diseases
that are associated with Expressions
such as diabetes were at higher risk
question for Stan and then so from the
moderator
you mentioned the nursing homes and uh
with respect to uh and then also there's
all people who live alone or two old
people live alone I would have think
would have thought that the one thing
about nursing homes that makes Focus
protection simple is that one thing you
don't do is what the swedes do or what
Cuomo did you don't send infected people
to the nursing homes the nursing homes
are already isolated so just make sure
you seal them and protect them in
different ways so when we assume that
that's a fairly simple solution for
focused protection and secondly you also
have old people let alone and so you get
them the groceries and then you have the
Third Kind the multi-generational and NJ
said the different solutions for them
but in the nursing homes and the old
people live alone are fairly simple
Focus protection policy available for
them
well 20 of them in the state of
Connecticut died in the year 2020. so it
was done you weren't protected they
weren't protected and we had no plan to
protect them well well that's the other
question you you said are you going to
let me answer or do you want to keep
asking questions
so my point is that um we were poorly
capacitated
and if as a as a public health academic
who used to work in the public sector in
public health I'm happy to look at a
mirror and criticize because
um there was no anticipation of this
magnitude of respiratory disaster even
though the CDC in 2017 had Rewritten its
guidelines for pandemic prevention and
most of those recommendations were
completely ignored during the Obama
Administration we learned how to make
kn-95 masks by the millions we learned
how to make affordable
ventilators that could be produced but
we didn't make the masks and we didn't
make the ventilators we just we just we
just
prepared for it so you come to March
April May we don't have care for the
nursing home people putting them in
empty hotel rooms it doesn't exist we
don't have a plan
and what happened was again the social
determinants of a disease the wealthiest
nursing homes
had the better paid employees who did
not have to go to their second job
and did not have to mix across nursing
homes it was a a
social disaster because the poorer you
were the more uh that you were a person
of color the more likely you were to die
in a nursing home the Richer you were
the wider you were the less like you
were going to die so it was that context
in which
we couldn't snap our fingers and created
uh Focus protection it was not possible
therefore we had lockdowns as well I
want you to come in but I just want to
ask a follow-up question you you you
speak perhaps very understandably about
the problems of the past but we're of
course are looking to the Future so
wouldn't you say then that for the
future Focus protection of that kind can
be put in place for the nursing homes
if we did that we would be doing
something extraordinary
it will take an awful lot of investment
and we aren't good at investing in
public health our health care System
that has all sorts of perverse
incentives for us to invest in care
that comes through our insurance schemes
one in three dollars of the American
dollar goes to insurance companies
ballooning our costs and public health
is paid through tax dollars through
different schemes and we vastly under
invest in in public health
so if we had commensurate investments in
public health so that we had a plan to
relocate 17 500 nursing home patients in
Connecticut nursing homes on on in the
space of two weeks into protected uh uh
circumstances like empty hotel rooms and
we had people to care for them but
that's a bit of a pipe dream at the
president Trump isolate the people in
Mexico but you wouldn't accomplish yes I
mean just a couple comments one is uh
what sen is talking about is he's right
is that there's that five-star nursing
homes did better at protecting their the
residents than than lower quality
nursing homes
you can't overnight turn one star
nursing homes into five-star nursing
homes what you can do is recognize that
one star nursing homes are at risk and
not send covert infected patients back
to them the idea isn't to like take all
17 500
residence nursing is out of out of
nursing homes and put them in hotel
rooms to isolate and the idea is to move
resources to protect the nursing homes
where they are not put them at
heightened risk right so for instance we
knew very early on that nursing home
employees who worked in multiple nursing
homes are tracking covet into multiple
nursing homes
that's a policy that could easily have
been changed we spent six trillion
dollars we could have paid nursing home
staff to stay on campus for a two weeks
at a time and not go back in and out it
would have taken creativity it would
have taken thought not
trillions of dollars although we did
spend trillions if we spent it more
wisely in the service of focus
protection we could have protected those
those nursing home patients much better
it wouldn't have not had been perfect
anyone that tells you that is lying to
you but we it could have been much
better
um the uh option to ask each other a
question right now anyone put into the
audience either one well since I agree
with what Jay just said I don't need to
ask him a question no question if you
usually 8210 okay uh question sir
please ask your question like as a
question and only one question and
unfortunately there's no follow-up well
regarding Sweden uh in a Tom Woods
newsletter that came out a few days ago
he released the published a um a graph
on excess debts released by the
organization for economic cooperation
and it does say that Sweden had 1800
deaths per million and Norway had 600
but in terms of excess total excess
death percentages Sweden's only 6.7 and
Norway is 6.9 it was a puzzling numbers
and
do you feel that either one is more
significant than the other the total
excess deaths or the the raw number per
million Stan and do you want to answer
that and then kind of check comment
there is
um there are some subtle differences in
the age distribution of Sweden and
Norway
uh Norwegians live a little bit longer
than swedes and they're a somewhat
higher proportion of elderly in Norway
so there are many other reasons why
Norwegians might die at uh from
non-coveted reasons at higher rates so
one would have to age standardize those
data to have a fair comparison
and uh I think the covet data speak for
themselves
so so the uh Johnny unities and Mike
Levitt who's a Nobel Prize owner at
Stanford and Johnny needs is a colleague
of mine Stanford did a very extensive
study of all cause access deaths with
age standardization the Scandinavian
countries come out pretty close to each
other near the top of Europe
all cause excess death is the right
measure because it's a it's essentially
it looks and says okay we've adopted
these policies what happened all the way
across
um there is no perfect example of focus
protection anywhere no country did it
perfectly I'll just use a data point
from the United States uh Florida which
had which locked down in early early in
the pandemic but then lifted the
lockdowns much earlier versus California
the age-adjusted mortality from covet is
roughly equivalent
and the all-cause excess deaths
again age-adjusted are lower in Florida
through the whole pandemic than
California looking at 2020 alone it was
actually better in Florida than in
California
it's not right to just look at 2020.
that's that's cherry picking when
Andrews technol the Swedish Health
Minister was asked whether in 2020
whether whether Swedish Sweden picked
the right policy said we have to wait a
year to see because the effects of the
lockdowns are long and extended and
public health is a long-term thing not a
short-term thing if you look through the
pandemic you will be hard-pressed to
find examples show a data showing that
the lockdowns actually protected people
over the long period long period of time
since the pandemic began
uh next question okay we have heard and
that's part of the debates anecdotes
cherry picking and red herrings
all these small isolated events and I
have a question regarding something much
more fundamental we know that the only
thing that stops respiratory virus
disease epidemic is hurt immunity
Governors running around and collecting
viruses somewhere is not working and
China shows us that even if you take the
military for to enforce a lockdown it
doesn't work in the long run
so we have to protect the vulnerable
as much as we can and we won't be
perfect while everybody else contributes
and takes responsibility for
contributing to the build up of herd
immunity
If instead
the instead of protecting or providing
protection to the vulnerable as much as
they want it want it
before us everybody else to do exactly
the same thing that the vulnerable
should do to protect them or could do to
protect themselves the vulnerable have
no Advantage anymore
and more of them get infected and they
are the people who die
so if they're more than one million
deaths that we had from Carver
without lockdowns it may have been a
hundred thousands
the question is
and show it the question is
why not focusing on the fundamental
principles of epidemiology why all these
red herrings cherry picking and
anecdotes I think the questions
challenging you stand to maybe take it
first
there are a lot of
serious respiratory diseases we used to
have smallpox
we have influenza every single year we
have respiratory Synthesia virus we have
para influenza viruses it goes on and on
and on there's no such thing as flu
season it's really respiratory virus
season because there's a whole family of
viruses
um if you let these go rampant none of
them infects and none of enough of us to
achieve herd immunity it is simply not
possible to have that degree of
efficiency of transmission there's only
one virus I can think of in which you
could saturate a population kill some of
them but protect everybody and that's
measles
measles is the one that is so infectious
that if one if we were all susceptible
and one of us had measles half the room
would be infected tonight well in just
in just the form that we've had uh we
used to see children get measles uh when
when when somebody came into the office
at eight in the morning was hustled out
by the nurse a child could come in at 10
11 in the morning and get measles from
that child so with the exception of
measles none of these others is going to
achieve herd immunity by simply letting
it run rampant this is one of the
failures I think of the
focus protection concept that somehow
magically we're going to have all the
rest of us are going to transmit this
been relatively benign virus because
we're not at risk and we're young and
will achieve herd immunity now that we
have a vaccine we can achieve herd
immunity and in the Northeast we're
coming pretty close our our our
circumstances are far more favorable
than than than parts of the country uh
Mississippi Wyoming that are less than
50 percent vaccinated we're up in the
high 70s in many of the states in the
Northeast uh however the Delta and
Omicron variants are more infectious
than the ancestral strain was and it may
be quite plausible that we need 85 90
coverage to truly achieve herd immunity
we still have one or two patients dying
every single day in the Yale New Haven
Hospital most of them unvaccinated so we
still have enough people with 23 percent
unvaccinated some of them got covid but
the fact that the immunity is waning so
it's it I couldn't agree with the
question or more that that herd immunity
is where it's at but we've got a
tremendous Public Health Challenge ahead
of us to coax our reluctant friends and
colleagues around the country to get
vaccinated
uh coming from you Jay yeah so I think
there's a lot of errors in this thinking
about how herd immunity actually works
uh Stan is right about how measles works
if you get measles in recover you are
not going to get it again you're not
going to transmit it again if you get
the vaccine from measles you are not
going to get measles you're not going to
transmit it that is not true for covet
you get coveted and recover you actually
have quite good protection but you are
likely to get infected again
um with less severe disease the second
time around if you get the vaccine
you're going to get coveted I had the
vaccine two of two doses in April by
April 2021 and I got covered in August
of 2020. if I asked the room I bet
everyone would raise their nearly
everyone raised their hands about the
vaccinated and getting covered this fact
soaked hurt immunity through vaccination
is a pipe dream
if you think about her immunity like you
think about measles
what you can ask for what you can expect
is is a sufficiently large fraction of
the population either covered or covered
and or vaccinated and now you have a
relatively protected population not
against disease transmission this
disease is here to stay forever
but against severe disease on infection
and so the notion of herd immunity
actually it's it's led to this mistake
has led to tremendous social harm for
instance by these vaccine mandates which
came about on the idea that have
sufficiently large fraction of the
population were vaccinated the disease
essentially would be less would no
longer be a danger no with much less
transmission that was not true as we see
from highly vaccinated countries getting
severe disease like getting large
disease outbreaks over and over again
this I this problem the problem of like
you know very prominent Health officials
misunderstanding this has led to
tremendous distrust in public health and
tremendous social harm but it's a little
off topic it's not exactly about Focus
protection so um we can talk well
actually the vaccine should have been
used for Focus protection could have
been uh that Sweden did actually they
vaccinated all every dose that they had
early on they used for older people
and and it what it did was in the spring
wave it decoupled cases from deaths in
the spring wave in 2021 uh in Sweden
because they were only vaccinated maybe
10 of their population but nearly every
single dose went to an old person and so
you had a huge wave of cases and very
few deaths per case compared to the the
winter wave which was which was earlier
so I think this is It's a complicated
point but uh it's led to a lot of
mistakes in communication and in policy
making
um
a lot of people don't understand how
vaccines work so what happens with the
vaccine you're given the antigen that
mimics the agent that's out there that's
a threat and so we give you an antigen
sometimes it's a weakened version of the
actual virus sometimes a killed version
of the virus sometimes it's just a viral
protein sometimes it's a it's a a mimic
of the virus but without the DNA
material or RNA material in it so it
resembles the surface of the protein all
sorts of different viruses the MRNA is
another example
and it doesn't do a spectacular job
preventing infection
none of them we thought hepatitis B
vaccine
resulted in sterilizing immunity meaning
that it was like a like a uh you know uh
Dr Spock and uh Captain Kirk and it's
like a force shield no it's more like
you you're you're you're you're you've
got the Klingons coming on board and you
know they're coming so you're prepared
to zap them as soon as they land in in
whatever that machine is where they
appear that's more the what what
vaccines do they're they're they're
infection permissive and the body then
sees the antigen and responds very
quickly with the what we call an
animastic response Amnesia I forgot and
Amnesia I remembered so the anamnesia
response is how you control it and even
uh Hepatitis B one of the best vaccines
we ever created when you look at a
surgeon who or a nurse who has a uh a
needle stick you will see see their
antibody rise meaning that that person
was in fact infected so what Jay says is
absolutely right in this case we're
going to need boosters to minimize the
symptomatic infection rate we're not
going to know what the asymptomatic
infection rate is but we don't care
because it's asymptomatic you're not
sick fine but what we're looking for
with high vaccine coverage is
essentially herd immunity for
hospitalization
we want herd immunity so people don't
get hospitalized and die
next question hi uh my name is David
perella I'm an Interventional
neurologist and I uh I spent the
pandemic at least in March April May uh
in the outer boroughs where I saw a
complete collapse of the system
um
I mean the day I got to the hospital and
my parking spot was gone because two
freezer trucks what's your question so
my question is I like the idea of focus
protection I think Focus protection
makes an immense amount of sense in a
post-vaccine world the question that I
have is at what point do we if this is
for Dr buckshire at what point do you
need a lockdown because from my
perspective
what we were seeing the outer boroughs
of Manhattan was you were if you came
into the hospital with a large vessel
occlusion if you came in with a trauma
if you came in with an MI you died I
mean there's just no way around it there
was an excess mortality because we
didn't have the resources uh there so I
like the notion of focus protection for
me I need more of a plan and I also need
to know what that Fail-Safe would be is
it an infectious fatality rate is it
some other metric I just
again we talked about lockdown to talk
about them universally what I'm looking
at specifically is this this initial
period specifically it would have been
end of March April early May New York
City
I think at that point the lockdown made
sense but I've gotten everything wrong
about this virus do you asked me two
weeks before it happened I would have
been like yeah don't worry
question is clear uh Jay yeah thank you
thank you for that question and uh thank
you for your service during that time um
I I think that the problem is the
lockdowns didn't
which we had didn't stop those cases
from happening it's not socially
possible to have a lockdown that would
protect against that what you just
described uh because the lockdown the
way the social determined system is
talking about
they apply even during a lockdown
richer people can protect themselves can
stay home stay safe it's a virtue right
but it's not a virtue because the single
mom with their their kid is on Zoom
she's a nurse in the hospital has to
make a difficult decision uh poor people
can't really lock down the lockdowns
essentially our focused protection of
the laptop class instead of focused
protection of the vulnerable
the plan for Focus protection the
vulnerable first recognize who the
vulnerable are and then use local
resources to try to protect them in in
New York it would have been really
simple to not send covert infected
patients to nursing homes than you would
have had many fewer cases and less
overwhelmed Hospital systems
um I I think uh uh if you want a
detailed plan you have to you have to
you have to ask the local public health
authorities to come up with those
detailed plans they're necessarily local
in nature
uh that's why the great branching
declaration is one page it was a call an
invitation for local public health to
engage with that we now know better
right we know the lockdowns didn't work
to protect the vulnerable
let's use the new opportunity we have in
the meantime to make local plans for
that kind of focus protection
um I the other thing I think and you
highlighted this in your excellent
question
um the Panic itself served no purpose
it created policy lock it created
difficulty and honest discussions with
each other so we could learn from each
other I mean Stan wasn't it was a big
exception to this where he actually read
the debate with me twice during the
pandemic which is I mean a unique thing
but um I couldn't get anyone in my
University debate with me it was it was
it was really something else because of
the panic
and I think I think it's hard to say
specifically because there's so many
different in Mumbai it's going to be
very different than in La than it's
going to be in New York and in Billings
or wherever every single place every
single local public Authority should be
tasked with asking how would you protect
this population that you're responsible
for that's living in your in your area
that should be the focus of Public
Health
coming from Houston
I would agree that we had no choice but
a lockdown in March April of 2020. for
the reasons that our neurologist friend
has articulated and there is a very
intro we're learning every day papers
are coming out every day new analyzes
every day there's one that's out
in preprint form now uh published in
epidemiology a respectable Journal this
year by Jorge Ledesma and colleagues and
they looked at the stringency index
four states how stringent were they in
containment and closures and also they
looked at something called a trip ratio
the trips that you took in 2020 compared
to what you did in 2019 pre-covet and
the combination of this stringency index
and the trip ratio correlates
beautifully with incidence rates the
more efficient the lockdown and the
fewer violations of that lockdown the
lower the instance rates it's it's
common sense if if everybody in this
room is tight and and boxed up versus
separate we know from airplane studies
and train studies of tuberculosis and
flu that it's the people sitting in the
adjacent seats on that plane that have
astronomical risk of acquiring it during
that six hour flight to La compared to
the people who are sitting a little
further away so it's not that that
distancing is an arbitrary concept it's
a well-honed concept masks are a
well-known Concept in public health and
we weren't arbitrarily taking
lockdowns and saying well we we were
decompressing Society we were we were
reducing the probability that an
infectious individual would encounter a
susceptible individual and that was not
irrational and I think that's exactly
what we needed to do now with high
vaccine rates we can be far more liberal
I'm not wearing a mask this evening I
don't see too many masks because we have
balanced assessment of our risks and
given low background incidence rates and
given High immunity rates we have a
degree of confidence that if we get
coveted it won't be so serious those of
you who are not vaccinated perhaps that
doesn't apply to you but the point is
it's a circumstance where we can start
thinking more creatively and please Jay
don't say one more time I've bit my
tongue that that somehow sending
infected covet patients back to nursing
homes was a reflection of the lockdown
strategy that was just stupid and
borderline criminal Behavior
oh that would be great
I I have a paper published in the Eureka
Journal of of clinical investigation
it's one of the highly excited papers in
the in the uh in this genre of what the
lockdown Effectiveness is turns out that
uh countries regions that locked down
did not actually control the spread and
specifically in terms of of shelter and
place orders and and business Force
business closures did not actually have
lower case spread then uh than uh
countries that did and in fact large
meta-analyzes found that that that that
that that correlation that's done
mentioned doesn't stand up when you when
you when you uh when you when you do
careful causal analysis you don't have
randomized controlled trials as Stan
said but uh it's not actually true that
the lockdowns were effective in stopping
uh people walking around people it's
just not that's why Ledesma used the
stringency criteria and uh and and tried
to parse out lockdown versus no lockdown
no that's not what he's doing we were
very careful too in that I mean okay
yeah it's just it's not this is a this
is a contentious issue do you think you
can make an analysis at a country level
a vast country what state level country
level it was a sub-regional level okay
yeah we just heard from standing by
criminal behavior in New York state and
in Sweden uh let that be a lesson to us
all uh a final question I'm afraid
because we're running out of time what's
your final question
stand in your rebuttal to Jay you said
that uh
Sweden adopting the recommendation for
social distancing distancing in February
or November 2020 was a deviation from
Focus protection policies but if I
understood Jay correctly in his earlier
rebuttal to you he said that that
policy was completely consistent with
focused protection as he defined it so
my question is do you unders do you guys
understand what Focus protection means
or what counts as in and what doesn't
and in a fundamentally different way
I'm not going to explain to Jay what
Focus protection is he's the author of
this concept as I understand Focus
protection let the virus spread among
the population don't disrupt the economy
don't disrupt anything let it spread
among the less vulnerable and try to
protect the more vulnerable that's what
I understand Focus production to be I'd
amend that with one one thing it's not a
question of let open schools is a good
example are we letting the virus spread
when we open schools no we're letting
school happen the virus may or may not
spread
um
foreign
policies that are cognizant of who's a
high risk and moving resources Ingenuity
and creativity to protect those
populations anything that does that is
focus protection
um that segues into the final part of
the evening I think unfortunately uh no
time for your question both of these
gentlemen are coming to a party
afterwards and you can Corner them then
with your questions and uh and they're
obviously both you will and they're both
very approachable and so uh uh five
minutes of summary from Jay Falls by
five minutes of summary from Stan Jay
you can take the podium again
thank you everybody
um I mean this was this is a fantastic
night to to have these these
conversations I want to close by asking
not not what happened in the past but
what we should do in the future
and I want to I want you to ask yourself
honestly did what we did what did what
we do what we did did it actually work
we we abandoned basic principles of
Public Health in March of 2020. we
effectively gave in to panic we adopted
policies that had no empirical basis
even even for instance six foot
distancing there was no study that said
six foot distancing
uh we had it we we adopted policies that
made the pop the population at large
fear the disease so much that that they
didn't invite their their uh in-laws to
to Thanksgiving or something or things
like that we basically created a
situation where where we still think of
each other as biohazards even
asymptomatic people
is that policy was it actually
constructed did it actually lead to good
outcomes
a million people have died from covet in
the in in the United States at least uh
uh many more around the rest of the
world
but the the the policy effects of
lockdowns
the harms are actually greater
100 million people thrown into poverty
that's very bad for health
tens of millions of people thrown into
dire food insecurity those are those are
not just simply economic harms those are
the policy outcomes from the lockdown
decision we made the decision we made to
panic the population
the severity of the disease requires a
commensurate response that commensurous
response is not locked down that
commencement response is a intelligent
focused protection uh we should so then
therefore going forward what what should
we do
I say that what we should do is we
should ask Public Health agencies if
Stan says that there's no plan uh for
local Focus protection make those plans
so that we don't want that we don't
tempted to lock down again that lockdown
policy was a disastrous failure the
school closures that we both agree was
was it was a tremendously harmful thing
and I think uh if we if we decide to not
do that if we decide okay that just
happened and let's move on uh what will
happen is we will lock down again
the the the the the precedent has been
set and unless we make a conscious
decision to not lock down again we will
I propose to go back to the old plan
the plan that worked before and actually
apply it even in the midst of a
difficult pandemic even in the midst of
a of a pandemic where we're tempted to
panic but we but we don't
um the probably the most important
failure of the lockdown was this spread
of panic was this this essentially this
selfish desire to protect ourselves if
we could if we had the resources to do
so
we have to go back to a policy that is
more Humane a policy that recognizes
who's really vulnerable recognizes that
there are people among us that don't
have the resources to lock down
recognizes that we're actually
interconnected and that decisions that
we make in rich countries have enormous
effects negative effects on on poor
countries if we if we if we break our
promises to them as we have as we did
um the the lockdown policy I think will
go down in history as the single biggest
mistake in public health history a
single biggest disaster in public health
history we have to uh if and if we don't
as a community go back and do an honest
assessment of it
we will repeat it again and again
forever and I think I'm glad that this
conversation is still happening it's
something that we should ask our elected
officials let's have a church commission
let's have a an honest assessment not to
put people in in jail or whatever for
for the problems that have been caused
but rather to do an honest assessment
what happens so that we can revise our
planning for next time when in medicine
when a patient dies uh there's a there's
a conference called a morbidity
mortality conference people get together
the doctors and nurses and others who
are managing the patient to die get
together and sometimes it's a very
pointed discussion about what happened
but the goal is to blame but the GLA the
goal is to learn and uh and I think uh
I'm delighted that Sten agreed to do
this that's the spirit in which I
entered this conversation I think that's
also the spirit that's then entered it
and I think that's also the spirit in
which we we as a people need to demand
our Public Health officials our
political officials to also engage in
this in this discussion so that we just
so that when we go forward we have a
better result next time thank you very
much
thank you Jay very articulate
the
circumstances of 2020
were unprecedented
for a hundred years before we had not
seen anything like it
and we responded uh aggressively
with measures
that would reduce the efficiency of
transmission from person to person it
was an extraordinary time in our history
I hope it will be the only time in our
lives where we experience such a thing
we had no plan for focused protection
we had no investment we had no Workforce
we had no venues
and to say that Focus protection would
have resulted in fewer dead Americans
and worldwide then the lockdowns did I
think is without an Evidence space
conspicuously without an Evidence base
um I believe that going forward uh we
are unlikely to see a pandemic threat of
the magnitude of what we just saw the
only reason I say that is because we
didn't see one for 100 years
on the other hand
um when I was a kid there were 2.4
billion people on earth now there are
seven point almost 9 billion and we're
closer and closer to Natural populations
from Once RNA viruses often spring
uh and uh it I may it may be that we do
see another pandemic in 20 years or 50
years just as bad as covet
and I would be pleased if we had nursing
home plans in place I would be pleased
if we had
um uh proper Public Health anticipation
it's the it's the ignoring of the 2017
CDC revised pandemic Plans by our policy
makers that put us in the mess that we
found ourselves in in 2020. so I think
there's a lot of common ground that Jay
and I could agree on
but I don't believe that we should buy
in to a focused protection plan that is
uh not well crafted it has no specifics
attached to it is reflecting a single
page of the Great Barrington uh and
simply saying
Public Health people you figured out
I think there's a lot that we Public
Health people have to figure out
how to protect vulnerable populations is
absolutely part of that equation
but to say that we would never do a
lockdown again to me that is like saying
we'll never have a Spanish Flu we'll
never have a coronavirus again I can't
say that we might in which case we may
want to do what we did last time which
is separate us spread us out as best we
can
and and reduce the probability of an
infectious person encountering a
susceptible person which is fundamental
Public Health principle now I hope we
don't have a president who is a
not encouraging mask use is encouraging
specious drugs that don't work that is
essentially politicizing Public Health I
think one of the one of the saddest
circumstance of this pandemic other than
all the harms that Jay correctly pointed
out is the politization of Public Health
I don't think that we need to be
politicizing whether the sewage
treatment plan isn't working and is
polluting our local Lake I don't think
we need to be politicizing whether we
have lead in our drinking water as Flint
Michigan had I don't think we need to be
politicizing the need for vaccinating
children and adults against vaccine
preventable diseases there is a a huge
array of issues in which Republicans
Democrats Libertarians green party red
party whatever it is can get together
and agree to row the auras in the same
direction I think that's why Jay and I
have been doing these debates because
the more we see each other the more we
debate our opposing views the more we do
see common ground and I want to thank
him for our very civilized discourse
thank all of you for coming and
especially thank our organizers this is
uh an amazing event I believe in debate
I think that when we don't have enough
of it we make poor decisions so let's
keep debating let's keep discussing
these issues and uh and get it right
next time thank you
foreign
Tootsie Roll which does go to the winner
of the Oxford style debate Focus
protection as set forth in the great
Banks and declaration should be the
principle of Public Health Management of
Highly infectious respiratory virus
pandemics uh Jane you've opened the
final vote vote yes no or undecided on
the resolution including those who are
watching on live stream and uh yeah so
that's the password to get into
the uh app on that and uh I guess what
you want to throw up the uh Brett you
want to throw up the promotion of the
swag we're selling while you're voting
uh we uh we do we do look for uh raising
of funds to fans these operations
amazingly enough your ticket sales and
even some of the contributions that have
been made are not enough for us to step
up certain efforts which we want to step
up next year and and uh and so we will
be selling uh swag uh Soul form swag
which is uh What uh it's uh it's bags
it's um it's whatever else I and I guess
we're not throwing up the the swag much
to my much to my happiness because all
of it features caricature of me and uh
and I did not request it I did not know
anything about what what Jay
you ski this is the first time I'm
actually seeing it this evening it was
not not a decision that I made but I
just I told Jane and Brett and the
others that I guess they had had a
better sense of what people would want
to buy I personally can't imagine that
anybody would want to buy this stuff
okay but but apparently I've been told
I'm wrong and it is true that it does
bring in money if you buy it and uh and
and apparently and this has been
regarded as as
um is obviously a favorable
representation does me does me honor uh
the uh the particular look and it does
relate to my most embarrassing moment as
a debater I did debate a young man who
was a socialist and I did tell him to
learn some economics and I got
and and I got quite annoyed with him
unlike these two guys on this stage
who've been quite polite to each other I
did get rather rude to that young man
and uh and and I've and I've never been
able to live it down certainly not been
able to live it down with my staff and
so and so they uh they want to haunt me
with that learn some economic the mug
what is it the mug the sock The Notebook
my God you can't do without any of this
stuff the indoor pills and it's all
going to be on sale uh it is what you
can buy it right now Jane is that
correct yeah you can go on our website
and buy it right now yeah and uh and
while we're so while we're voting
however I also want to make an
announcement about next month's uh
debate that's going to be Wednesday
December 14th again in this Hall and uh
we're gonna get National Review
editor-in-chief Richard Lowry to come to
our Hall uh even more of an honor than
getting Stan verman my God and uh and he
will defend the resolution very
different nationalism is an important
value that Americans should support that
will be defended by a National Review
editor-in-chief Richard Lowry and taking
the negative will be Cato Institute
senior fellow Alex narasta and then also
next year we're going to Institute a new
initiative that I'm going to be talking
about on later in the week and those who
will be invited to the initiative
initially will be those who are on our
Facebook page the Facebook page is
called what again Jane it's called I
keep forgetting it sent what so forming
a circle if you go on the cell phone in
the circle and become a member then you
can get first dibs to be a part of our
new initiative which I'm only going to
outline once I write it to the Inner
Circle our donors will be invited as
well as our volunteers on the initial
phase to come in to that new initiative
that's starting in January and that's
going to cost us money we go believe we
can afford it it will help very much if
you make a contribution by for example
buying some of this ugly swag and uh and
uh and uh and uh on Thursday January
26th uh we are going to have a debate on
the Federal Reserve George Mason
University professor of Economics
Lawrence white will defend the
resolution replacing the Federal Reserve
with free market institutions would
significantly improve the economy's
money Banking and Financial systems and
arguing against that resolution will be
Columbia University professor of banking
and financial institutions Lawrence
Michigan so that's January 26th and how
are we doing on the voting uh Jane we're
still still coming in yeah
oh radicals okay uh uh drum roll please
as Jane brings it up to me and I hold in
my hand the soul from tootsie roll and
uh and then also again I I know where uh
follow me uh particularly Stan you don't
know it's two blocks Uptown please
follow me stand to the to the
refreshments at our place and when you
can meet and greet and Jay you you did a
little interview at our places so follow
Jay because he knows what the place is
and uh and uh and so here we have the
res the the results drum roll please
um okay uh the yes on the resolution
began at
56.7 percent and it went to 81 picking
up 24 points so that's the number to
beat uh Stan you did pick up votes of
eight points but 24 points pick up for
uh the resolution means that Jay butter
gets the tutorial
congratulations to you both
[Applause]